[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup par fabienne ouais ouais
bah on a eu un petit truc en fin mai
soit instruite en les regards onéreux au
monde d'accord des loges ce que vous
pensez que vous
non je la regardais en tout cas mal à
vous poser avec fabienne lupo être son
style souhaité que les réponses
partielles courage de l'avouer je pense
fabienne on va attendre la fin de mai
comptait dire quoi mais non mais dis le
mais non c'est pas votre délire mais je
ne suis pas là dedans mais dans quoi
[Rires]
oui autrement autrement quoi si vous
mettiez célibataire mais non mais je
veux pas mais non j'ai espéré
j'ai je t'avoue cette personne mais vous
avez la possibilité d'être désinfecté
comment mais jean michel sabbat l'insee
non mais
on parlera après c'est très gênant la
marque dès la séquence